for years our world has been a piece
that something is coming I can feel it
dark forces are upon us a world is dying
if I'll people ought to survive we must
make a whole media Warcraft is a huge
scale movie it's the high wire act of
filmmaking
from the first moment the film opens its
larger than life this film has wonderful
characters get on and amazing creatures
it's stuff that you've never seen before
step in the Oaks world is dying it's
become a desert they had no choice but
to find another world let me go first
most of them wanted coexist peacefully
and find a new home but the leader of
the orcs once ultimate power clean my
new majesty since something dark forces
these monstrous beings attacking our
people our whole world is in trouble oak
around you wherever gold and works his
magic the land eyes for works there is
no the life of war no but with the
humans help there could be one of the
unexpected surprises is the way our
heroes end up coming together why are
you here to save our people this is the
only way to survive orcs and humans have
to work together I'll have made a
protection I need nothing to protect me
inside of the humans against your own
kind you're right despite in a different
system come together to defeat the
common enemy trust in your friend
together you can save this world
you're talking about a scale of war that
you've never seen before
is unique and really exciting
you